.
[BLEEP].
>> Tucker: TO BE CLEAR, KIDS
WERE THERE BECAUSE ORGANIZERS
WANTED KIDS TO BE THERE.
YOU SEE AN EVENT PAGE FROM BEST
DRAG SHOWS.COM.
THE BOTTOM OF THE FLIER SAYS
MINORS ARE ALLOWED IF
ACCOMPANIED BY A PARENT OR
GUARDIAN.
THIS IS NOT A CRIME IN TEXAS.
IT'S A HUGE MORAL CRIME THAT
NOBODY SHOULD ACCEPT.
YOU ARE NOT TOLERANT IF YOU
ACCEPT THIS.
SEXUALIZING CHILDREN IS THE MOST
WRONG THING AT ALL.
SARAH GONZALES DID SOMETHING
ABOUT IT.
WORKS AT BLAZE TV.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR COMING
ON.
I AM MISREADING THIS?
I CAN'T SAY THE LYRICS ON TV.
THERE ARE KIDS THERE.
WHAT?
>> YOU ARE NOT MISREADING IT.
I WOULD SAY THERE WAS A LATER
PART OF THE EVENT WHERE THEY
HANDED OUT SEX TOYS AS PRIZES.
THIS WAS SEXUAL AND ALL AGES
WERE WELCOME.
NOW THEY ARE TRYING TO GASLIGHT
ME TO THINKING I AM CRAZY FOR
HAVING A PROBLEM WITH THIS.
THE EXCUSE IS I THOUGHT YOU WERE
THE PARTY OF PARENTAL RIGHTS.
IF YOU DON'T LIKE IT, DON'T TAKE
YOUR KIDS.
PARENTAL RIGHTS DOESN'T AFLY TO
THE SEXUAL BECAUSE OF CHILDREN.
THE LEFT AND RIGHT USEED TO SAY
WE COULD NOT DO THIS.
THE LEFT IS TRYING TO EXCUSE
THIS -- APPLY.
>> Tucker: THE WELL FUNDED GAY
RIGHTS GROUPS PUSHED FOR GAY
MARRIAGE AND GOT IT.
ARE THEY ON BOARD WITH THIS?
IT'S HARD TO BELIEVE THAT ADULTS
ARE FOR THIS BUT THEY ARE.
>> THERE IS A SUB-SECTOR OF
ADULTS WITHIN THESE
ORGANIZATIONS THAT DON'T AGREE
WITH IT, BUT THEY DON'T IS THE
COURAGE TO SPEAK UP.
THEY ARE SCARED OF BEING
CANCELED.
YOU HAVE TO BE ON THE RIGHT SIDE
OF HISTORY.
EVENTUALLY WE WILL WIN OUT.
YOU DON'T WANT TO BE CAUGHT ON
THE WRONG SIDE OR EXCUSING THIS
PAVER.
-- BEHAVIOR.
ANYONE WHO DOESN'T SPEAK OUT IS
CULPABLE REPUBLICAN OR DEMOCRAT.
>> Tucker: WHY WOULD YOU WANT TO
GET KIDS INVOLVED?
WE HAVE A FAIR DEAL.
YOU GO DO YOUR THING AND I DOLL
MY THING.
-- I WILL DO MY THING.
NO, WE HAVE TO GET KIDS
INVOLVED.
WHY?
>> I BELIEVE, TUCKER, IT'S
A MORE SINISTER ATTEMPT BY THE
LEFT.
THEY WANT THIS RADICAL COUNTRY.
THE ONLY WAY TO ACHIEVE THAT IS
THROUGH CHAOS AND CONFUSION.
CONFUSION CHILDREN ABOUT THEIR
GENDER AND EXPOSE THEM TO THINGS
THEIR LITTLE BRAINS ARE KNOW
READY FOR IT.
BIG DADDY GOVERNMENT WILL PICK
US UP AND TAKE CARE OF US AT THE
END.
>> Tucker: IT'S BEYOND BELIEF.
YOU CAN'T GET KI